some of
the biggest benefits of like progress
whether it's like quitting smoking and
all this kind of stuff
is in the is in the days after it's the
integration of the experience
so maybe you open up the brain to the
neuroplasticity but then there's like
work to be done it's not
you're like you shake up something in it
in the biology of the brain
but you have to do then it's work
absolutely
now a friend of mine who's a physician
he says um
who's quite open to this idea that
psychedelics could play a
real role in in real medicine he says um
better living through chemistry still
requires better living
and and i think it's it's a beautiful
statement i wish i had said it
be um but he gets the credit but
the plasticity window opens and then as
you said what are you gonna do in the
two weeks three weeks four weeks
afterward because that's the real
opportunity
but those psychedelic experiences are
really a case of an amplified experience
inside of an amplified experience so
much so that
everything seems relevant and it's um
it's it's fascinating i mean i my hope
is that
the ai and machine learning and the
brain machine interface and all that
will eventually be
merged with the psychedelic treatments
so that you
an individual can go in take whatever
amount of whatever's safe for them
working with a clinician and really
direct the plasticity while
maybe stimulating the orbital frontal
medial orbital frontal cortex
or increasing the observer or decreasing
the observer in the brain or
decreasing the amygdala i mean it's
doable it's doable with
transcranial magnetic stimulation and
it's for shutting down activity and it's
doable with ultrasound ultrasound now
allows very focal
activation of particular brain regions
through the skull
non-invasively so it's approaching the
same kind of uh
therapy from different angles one ai is
the computational side so
injecting like the robotics injecting
like
maybe you can even think about as like
electricity the electrical approach
versus then like the the chemical
approach absolutely
and then the psycho and then the
psychology is is subjective right
so it's going to take some real um
understanding of what that
person's um lexicon is like you know
that wasn't a pun i'm sorry
that's the one thing i know from the
feedback on my podcast my jokes are
terrible but i never claimed to be funny
the the uh but somebody who
they really trust and understands when
somebody says
you know for a very stoic person like
i'm imagining uh you interviewed the
great dan gable
right i don't know anything about dan
but can you imagine like you asked dan
like you know how you feel about
something while on one of these drugs
and like
i mean his languaging might if he says
that was troubling it might mean that it
was very troubling or not troubling at
all
so people are language is a poor
guide because if i say i'm upset how
upset is that well that's very
subjective
so you need we need can you build a tool
for that can you build a ai tool for
that yeah deeper
yeah maybe that's the eye maybe that's
our that's what the eyes could reveal
so language is not just words it's
everything together and that's
one of the fascinating things about the
eyes and the window to the soul i mean
they express so much the face the eyes
the body
uh i mean lisa talks about that the
communication of emotions
it's a super complex
you